LARRY DAVID: Gag gift?
No, that's a real gift.
You've never had one?
-You ever played around
with one?
-LARRY: No!
You cuddle it.
Whatever your journey is.
♪ ("EL DESEO"
BY JANET SHERBOURNE PLAYS) ♪
What exactly do you see
in this man?
I think behind
those dark clothes lies a--
(LAUGHS) Very pretentious man?
So, the bathroom's
gonna be over there.
I've got a lot of ideas
for the urinals.
You wanna redesign a urinal?
-Elevated planks.
-Great.
Your feet never touch
the ground.
-Why?
-That's where the puddles are.
Do you know what it takes to
stand up there for 90 minutes,
one-man play?
It must be quite grueling.
One wonders why
somebody would do it.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪